attias jean marie bigard qui maintenant
on va voir une blague de jean marie
bigard qui veulent briser mari je vais
l'appeler facetime s'agit d'appels tout
sud ont fait des tarifs je le rappelle
en fait hein qu'est ce qui se passe et
personne n'a appelé bras vous étiez là
c'est un naufrage marie désespéré alors
arrive regardez jean marie bigard qu'est
la manche jean marie bonjour marie
d'amours ça va mon chéri je n'étais pas
bien mon chéri la gt j'ai dû m'absenter
quelques minutes que pour des raisons
qui m'incombe
non mais ça va bien là je ne fais pas ça
moi alors j'avais j'avais un petit peu
de bricolage à faire en fait parce que
j'avais un cadre armes est un truc comme
ça je t'expliquerai bonjour marie
commence à voir mon bébé tu étais donc
toi t'es con fine et avec ta femme tes
[Musique]
vieux bac tu peux tu veux venir quand tu
veux mon cher bah quand tu veux tu es
toujours le bienvenu mon chéri que je
t'aime tu as pas une petite blague à
nous faire là pour nous détendre vas-y
vas-y situe juste saison c'est le mot
ouais doha disparaît complètement
il disait gratuit ma femme était comme
la tienne
j'étais bien caché un pistolet sous
l'oreiller jeux sorties piscine n'est
pas celle le fait flipper c'est il
accrocha mois des peurs ses mises à
mouiller j'ai retrouvé la fin j'avais
poussé à 25 ans et s'est dit d'accord
trois heures trois jours plus tard ils
se retrouvent le signaleur je te
remercie un ton idée de rêve mais
remercie beaucoup dit quoi merci
beaucoup a été fait aux tueries ont émis
leur gps
[Musique]
j'ai pris pistolet tiré du coup elle
maman merci mme rice était un petit peu
de matam c'était bien de mettre un petit
peu de finesse voilà d'or dans ce monde
de brutes
ah merde si votre chéri joe bar et tu
vas devoir quand tu étais mon chéri
bonjour salut des enfants bouffer des
gros bisous mes amours salut mes chéris
on vous aime fort on vous aime fort et
yallo là qu'on aime fort aussi qu'on
envoie salut - chéri hayden ont voté de
la prochaine fois on filtre war un petit
peu ouais je pense que c'est parce que
je pense je pense je pense que c'est pas
ça